tienen entre 5 y 12 años y no están
vacunados contra el kobe 19 pero desde
el domingo los niños israelíes vienen a
someterse a test para saber si ya
pasaron la enfermedad si la respuesta es
positiva significa que están inmunizados
es trabajo de mi hijo dio positivo en el
test de anticuerpos aparentemente
contrajo el virus sin que nos diéramos
cuenta así que dispondrá de un pase
sanitario y podrá ir al colegio con toda
seguridad
el objetivo de la campaña de test
serológicos gratuitos es garantizar el
regreso a clases el gobierno quiere
comprobar qué proporción de niños y
hasta inmunizado contra el hobbit 19
para no tener que aplazar la vuelta a
las aulas prevista para el 1 de
septiembre
paralelamente el país prosigue con su
política de la tercera dosis del fármaco
contra el cob y 19 para combatir la
propagación de la variante delta este
domingo el gobierno israelí rebajó a 40
años la edad requerida para recibir la
inyección de refuerzo
este fin de semana también aprobamos la
tercera dosis de la vacuna para las
personas de más de 40 años y de nuevo
somos los primeros del mundo en hacerlo
1 millón 400 mil israelíes ya recibieron
la dosis de refuerzos mosley en israel
el 58% de la población está
completamente vacunada cifra que cae
debajo del 10% en los territorios
palestinos ocupados